Speaker 1: Michael Knowles, on whose program I
have appeared. Now wants to ban transgender ism.
This is the latest in the confused and, quite
frankly, delusional, the delusionally obsessed,
anti-trans right wing. They have seized on the
idea that they are going to get attention by
just being obsessed about trans. And Matt
Walsh is essentially just known for being
anti-trans. And he's gotten great publicity
from it and great attention. And so now a
lot of these other right wing hangers on are
trying to mirror that and saying, you know,
if I just talk about trans people all the time,
I'm going to get attention. And right wingers who
don't know any better will will contribute and
it'll be great and they'll make money from it.
So here is Michael Knowles. And his new thing
is we just need to ban transgenderism. Ban it.
Speaker 3: Speaking of the law, as a
teacher. Yeah. Great new law in Kansas.
Kansas has become the first state to.
Speaker 1: By the way. What is it about
like the tapping of the paper that is so pompous
and pretentious? I don't know what it is about
that. I'll play it for you again. The great you
know, like great new law there taps the paper.
Something about that is just really annoying.
Speaker 3: Speaking of the law, as a teacher,
great new law in Kansas City. Kansas
has become the first state to pass a
bill that defines a woman as someone
who is biologically born female.
That's it. That's what a woman is. Which means
that this will ban men. And we will ban men who
identify as transgender women from using single
sex areas designated for women called the Women's
Bill of Rights. It was approved by legislators 26.
Speaker 1: Very powerful civil rights proposal.
Speaker 3: Written on Thursday.
Only Republican support there.
And the bill defines a female as
someone whose biological reproductive
system is developed to to produce over oh.
Speaker 1: Who's but now we're get that's
going to be a problem developed to produce ova.
Speaker 3: While male refers to anyone whose
reproductive system is developed
to fertilize the over of a female.
This is a beautiful bill because. It
doesn't just say don't trans the kids.
It doesn't just say wait till eight. To introduce
kids to transgenderism in schools once they turn
nine, that's fine. It doesn't just say only
minors can't. It's. It bans transgenderism.
For all practical purposes, in the state. For
everybody. And it has to. In order for women to
have the right to have their own bathrooms,
you have to ban transgenderism entirely.
Speaker 1: Ban it.
Speaker 3: You can't just ban it
for the kids. It's got to be entirely.
Speaker 1: While you're at it,
you should ban racism to order.
Speaker 3: For women to be able
to have their own locker rooms at the gym.
You have to ban transgenderism entirely.
Speaker 1: Ban it.
Speaker 3: In order to protect
businesses from having to participate in weird.
Speaker 1: Businesses must be protected
from transpeople.
Speaker 3: Occult sexual
rituals like the transgender transition.
You have to ban transgenderism entirely.
Speaker 1: Ban it. Okay. As you can
see, conservative. It's not even
I reflexively use the term conservative, but it's
really extremist, radical rhetoric. Extremist,
radical right wing rhetoric against trans people
is at bloodthirsty levels. Every. How boring is
it to just be a gay man anymore? And what I
mean by that tongue in cheek, of course, is
that they have moved on completely. They rarely
cared about lesbians. It used to be all about
trans men. I'm sorry about gay men. Now it is
all piled on to being in a bloodthirsty way
anti-trans. Now, of course, reasonable people
would say, how how do you ban transgenderism?
You can't ban transgenderism any more than you can
ban homosexuality. That being said, what they're
talking about is criminalizing specific acts or
behaviors or norms, I guess you would say. And we
know about the horrifying history of that. If
we look at that in history beyond just sexual
orientation and gender identity. Now, of course,
there's this whole related thing when you talk
about how you live versus what you feel and acts
versus all this stuff. There's this idea of one
of the dangers of transgenderism is people might
fake being trans either so they can get into the
women's bathroom and then photograph or whatever,
you know, things that are already against the law.
But when you zoom out and you look at the
level of bloodthirsty viciousness against
the trans community right now, why on
earth would anyone fake being trans,
given how horribly trans people are being
treated and the level of stigma against
them now? You know, I'm right there with you
in saying might someone experiencing strife
in their life wrongly come to believe for a
period that being in the wrong gendered body
is what's causing them the problem? And then
those people might explore that and then go, Oh,
you know what? This wasn't the issue. Actually,
the issue was something else, and they move beyond
it. Sure. Right wingers love to talk about it
and say, you know, there's all these people
who they they come out as trans, but then they go
back to living as the same gender that they were
that matches their genitalia, I think is the
way they like to say. Okay, fine. Right. I mean,
so like, somebody might wrongly, for whatever
reason, think maybe this is the issue and then
it's not. But the idea of the people faking being
trans in order to do all of these devious things,
like get into bathrooms. Everybody wants to get
into bathrooms and locker rooms. It's absurd. Now,
of course, with the whole banning thing, the
way this is defined, what happens if a woman's
reproductive organs were not properly developed?
By this definition, it sounds like that she's not
a woman. Oh, well, that's an exception. What if
you're born intersex? Oh, well, that's also an
exception. Oh, so we have exceptions. What makes
those exceptions any more legitimate than those
who have been diagnosed with gender dysphoria?
It's just at that point, it's just arbitrary. And
we saw a similar thing when the gun control
debate was about, well, you should just be
able to have all alarms. Oh, well, like what about
a shoulder mounted RPG or. Well, no, not that. Oh,
so you are okay drawing the line and making
exceptions. So now it's just a question of which
exceptions do you consider valid versus which ones
do I consider valid? And many of these right wing
arguments go down that path. So disgusting stuff
from Michael Knowles. Not surprising. We'll have
all of these clips on our YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.
Make sure you were subscribed to the channel,
folks, please. We just closed out February,
February or February. I don't care
however you want to say it. More than
3 million people who are not subscribed
to the YouTube channel watched our videos
too. You folks hit the subscribe button. It
won't hurt you in any way. It won't bite you.
It won't do anything to you other than a firm to
YouTube that you like what we're doing. And then.
They'll recommend our content to more people.
That's youtube.com slash The David Pakman Show.